so something in the game of thrones
books that mostly don't appear in the
show are the many dreams and visions the
characters have they have regular dreams
and nightmares about their hopes and
fears and memories but dreams can also
be connected to magic and prophecy some
Starks have wolf dreams inside the minds
of dire wolves and Targaryen have dragon
dreams of fire and blood red priests see
the future and past in their flames bran
and Jojen have green dreams with magic
trees and clay theses glass candles to
enter people's dreams point being lots
of characters in Game of Thrones have
weird visions often connecting to the
Future Passed magic and prophecy and
this is especially true of Daenerys
Targaryen
she has dragon dreams fever dreams
prophetic dreams glass candle dreams she
has a whole Vision Quest in the Dothraki
sea after eating some funny berries but
some of the most important and
interesting visions in the whole series
of the visions Dany has in the house of
the undying in Balkan season to Daenerys
comes to the city of Kaif and meets a
warlock called P at pray he invites her
to the house of the undying where he and
his warlock buddies live promising to
give Denny
great truth and wisdom in the show p @ /
he steals Danny's dragons to force her
to come but in the books she goes
willingly she comes to the entrance and
is offered a potion called shade of the
evening which p @ says will open her
mind to the truths within so Danny takes
the drugs offered by the strange man and
enters the house it's a strange magical
place full of passageways arranged in
impossible ways and there are endless
rooms where Danny begins to see visions
the first vision is the weirdest - Danny
sees a beautiful woman sprawled naked on
the floor while 4 little men crawl over
her biting and [ __ ] her body the way
this is usually interpreted the woman
represents Westeros and the four men
represent the four kings ravaging the
country with war it's kind of a gross
metaphor but it gets the point across
war is terrible and so perhaps are the
men who wage it the reason why there are
four men here instead of all five kings
of the war of the five kings is probably
that King Renly is dead
at this point in the story anyway
Danny's second vision is of a feast of
corpses she sees savagely slaughter'd
feast is strewn across overturned
furniture and a dead man with the head
of the wolf in an iron crown this is
pretty clearly the red wedding the dead
man is Robb Stark after the phrase so
his direwolf's head onto his corpse
interestingly this vision happens a
whole book before the red wedding does
so this is a great example of a vision
that accurately shows the future of the
story before it happens
Danny's next vision is of the past she
sees inside the house with the red door
which was a house in Braavos where
Daenerys and Viserys lived for a while
after they fled Westeros when Robert
Baratheon took over in Braavos Dany and
her brother were protected by Sir
William Derry a knight who stayed loyal
to the Targaryen until he died of some
sickness the house with the red door is
the closest place Dany has known to a
home and she dreams of it often as a
place of safety and comfort and a happy
simple life but the house with the red
door is also the subject of conspiracy
theories there's this whole thing about
how the house with the red door had a
lemon tree outside when trees are very
rare in Braavos so some people believe
that the house might actually have been
in Dorne as part of some Martell
conspiracy though the evidence for this
isn't very convincing Donny's fourth
vision is of her father the Mad King
Aerys Targaryen sitting the Iron Throne
Aerys says let him be the king of ashes
and what's going on here is that
heiresses army and son have just been
destroyed by Robert Baratheon at the
Battle of the Trident so Aerys is giving
the order to burn down King's Landing
so that Robert can't have it he would
have got away with it too if it weren't
for a young Jaime Lannister killing the
king and saving the city Danny's fifth
vision is of another dead Targaryen her
brother Rhaegar the eldest child of King
Aerys in the vision Rhaegar is with his
wife Elia Martell and with their newborn
son who they named Aegon Rhaegar says
that this child Aegon is the prince that
was promised the prince that was
promised or azor Ahai is a hero
prophesied to save the world when he was
young Rhaegar believed that he was this
hero but he laid
comes to believe it would be his son
aegon rigor also says the dragon has
three heads and there must be one more
so at this time raiga has two kids a
young daughter or a niece and now the
infant Aegon Aegon is the name of Aegon
the conquerer the original Targaryen who
took over Westeros 300 years ago this
egg on had two sister wives
Rhaenys and Visenya so it looks like
Rhaegar was naming his kids after these
original three Targaryen 's he just
needed a third child
Visenya to complete the set so that
seems to be what he means when he says
there must be one more a problem though
is that Rhaegar wife Elia was frail and
sickly and after the birth of Aegon the
maesters said she couldn't have more
kids
so Rhaegar had a problem how was he
going to have his third child his third
head of the dragon if Elia couldn't give
birth maybe this is part of the reason
why Rhaegar ran off with Liana stock of
course that led to Robert's rebellion
and the death of Rhaegar and the deaths
of Elia and Rainey's and Aegon so so
much for the prince that was promised in
the three heads of the Dragon
but with Liana Rhaegar did get to have
his third child Jon Snow Danny keeps
moving she encounters strange phantoms
that try to lure her into the wrong room
but she gets through and arrives at the
true chamber of the undying ones
themselves a group of immortal warlocks
who turn out to look like creepy blue
corpses there's a human heart floating
above it's like some scene from The
Binding of Isaac and the undying whisper
prophecies to Dany they say three fires
must you lash one for life and one for
death and one to love three mounts must
you ride one to bed and one to dread and
want to love and three treasons will you
know once for blood and once for gold
and once for love there are lots of
different ways to interpret these lines
but here are some likely answers the
fire to light for life is probably the
fire Dany lights to hatch her dragons to
give life to them the fire for death
could be a bunch of things because Danny
often kills people with fire but it's
probably the fire that Dan is just about
to use to kill the undying to
bring death to the deathless the mount
to bed is probably the silver horse
Danny rides to her first night with
Drogo the mounted red is probably her
dragon drogon who causes such dread in
Danny's enemies some people interpret
this mount thing differently arguing
that the mounts aren't literally animals
that Danny rides but they're actually
the men danny has sex with so you could
say his doll even potentially Euron is a
mount to dread maybe Drago is the mount
to love and his da is to bed or
something there are lots of different
arrangements but what seems to make the
most sense is just having the silver and
drogon as Danny's mounts so far
now the treasons the treason for blood
according to Danny is when Mary Mazda
kills Danny's unborn child Rhea go to
avenge her people who were killed by the
Dothraki the treason for gold
Danny believes his when Jorah reports on
her to varus but the thing is Jorah
didn't betray her for gold he just
wanted a pardon so that he could go home
to Westeros to any later thinks that
this treason is from Brown been plumb
cell sort captain who portrays her in
the books but he doesn't do it for gold
either so maybe the treason for gold is
yet to come
it could maybe be from Daario or Illyria
or the shave paid regardless this leaves
a fire tool of amount to love and a
treason for love a fire to love is
interesting wording because the other
fires were for life for death this is to
love does this mean Danny will love a
fire what could that mean well there's a
lot of speculation that Danny and Jon
Snow might fall in love and John could
represent fire in that he may be azor
Ahai who is said to wield a flaming
sword and represents light against
darkness the full wording here is that
Danny must light a fire to love so maybe
Danny will light the fire that makes
John azor Ahai this could connect to the
story of Nissa Nissa apparently the
original azor Ahai created his burning
sword Lightbringer by plunging his sword
into the body of his wife if Jon Snow is
azor Ahai maybe he'll have to do
something similar with Daenerys maybe
this could be the treason for love this
is all very vague but however you look
at
love and fire and treason seem to be in
Danny's future and John Snow and azor
Ahai could easily be a big part of that
oh and there's also a mount so maybe
Danny will ride ghost the undying say
some more stuff they call Danny child of
storm and daughter of death which refers
to Danny's birth she was born during a
storm and her mother died giving birth
to her the undying call her bride of
fire which again could connect to Danny
loving someone who symbolically is fire
and they also call her Slayer of Lies
which is an interesting one we'll get
back to this and they call Danny child
of three which could just refer to the
fact that she's the youngest of three
children but it could also connect to
the more general Targaryen number three
shenanigans because the undying also say
three heads has the dragon then the
undying give Danny a bunch more visions
at high speed she sees her brother
Viserys killed with molten gold by Drogo
she sees a tall Lord with copper skin
and silver gold hair standing beneath
the banner of a fiery stallion a burning
City behind him this is a cool one with
the skin of a Dothraki and the hair of a
Targaryen and a CD with both a horse and
Fire this guy must be Rago the son of
Daenerys and Drogo who was never born
because he was killed in the womb by the
magic of mirror master this vision is
what Danny's son would have become if he
had lived because Rhaegar was connected
to a prophecy of his own the - Colleen
tell Daenerys that her son would be the
stallion who mounts the world a great
Dothraki warrior who'd unite the callous
arse and take over the world but Rhaegar
died and the prophecy didn't come true
Dany then sees rubies flying like drops
of blood from the chest of a dying
Prince he sinks to his knees in the
water and with his last breath murmurs a
woman's name so this guy is Rhaegar
Targaryen again Danny's brother here
he's dying at the Battle of the Trident
killed by Robert Baratheon during his
rebellion the big question here is who's
named as Rhaegar murmur maybe he named
his wife Elia Martell but maybe he named
Lyanna Stark the woman he'd just run off
with and started this whole war of her
in the first place we're told by some
characters that Rhaegar Abdul
did and raped Liana but many readers
suspect that Rhaegar and Lyanna were
actually in love for now it's a mystery
but Rhaegar sangli Anna's name with his
last breath would add something
beautiful and tragic to this vision
Danny sees a blue-eyed King raise a red
sword that glows like sunset and this is
probably the blue eyed King Stannis
Baratheon raising his burning sword at
the beach on Dragonstone back when
Melisandre was trying to convince
everyone that Stannis was azor Ahai the
king in this vision casts no shadow
which probably hints at the magic shadow
creature with Stannis's face that
Melisandre conjures to kill Renly a
second way to interpret this vision
though is that it could be an image of
the future of the true azor Ahai like
maybe Jon Snow in the books will be
resurrected not as the same guy he was
before like in the show but maybe as
something different he could have the
blue eyes of a white his sword could
burn transformed as light bringer and he
could be a king as the king in the north
so maybe he could fit this vision it's
not super likely though Danny sees a
cloth dragon swaying on poles amidst a
cheering crowd which Danny later says is
called a mummer's dragon
so remember Aegon regards infant son who
died in Robert's rebellion well in the
books Varys and Illyrio claimed to have
secretly saved Aegon and to have raised
him to be a perfect King there's this
whole big conspiracy to put a gun on the
Iron Throne but the thing is the
evidence suggests that this Aegon
Targaryen isn't Aegon Targaryen at all
the kids are fake making him
symbolically
a mummer's dragon a fake Targaryen so
it's very interesting that the undying
cold a nice layer of Lies maybe Danny
will be the one to reveal Varys and
Illyrio's deceptions then Danny sees a
great stone based taking wing from a
smoking tower and breathing shadow fire
this one is tricky but is probably
related to Melisandre talk of waking a
dragon from stone at the island of
Dragonstone Mel wanted to sacrifice a
young boy called edrick storm use his
Kings blood to wake a stone dragon but
edrick is saved by Davos and it doesn't
end up happening
so perhaps this is another example of a
prophecy averted Danny sees her silver
trotting through the grass to a Darkling
stream beneath a sea of stars which
seems to be Danny on a horse on a
wedding night to Drago Danny sees a
corpse standing at the prow of a ship
eyes bright in his Dead face gray lips
smiling sadly this could be a bunch of
people theon greyjoy comes to mind
standing on a ship looking like a corpse
offed his torture by ramsey which was
much worse in the books it could also be
a book character Victorian corpse in the
sense that he's probably doomed to die
in slavers Bay or it could be Jon
connington looking dead and gray because
of the greyscale taking over his body
it's hard to be sure with this vision
Danny sees a blue flower growing from a
[ __ ] in a wall of ice filling the air
with sweetness the wall of ice has got
to be the wall right and as with a
flower blue winter roses are often
associated with Lyanna stark what's at
the wall that's connected to Leanna
Leanna son Jon Snow the imagery of Jon
filling the air with sweetness in
Danny's vision might again support the
idea of some romance between the two
Danny sees shadows whirling and dancing
inside a tent boneless and terrible and
this is the tent where merry master
performs the magic that kills the unborn
Rago and leaves Drogo living but
mindless Danny sees a little girl
running barefoot towards a big house
with a red door so this is that house in
Braavos again Danny sees Meera Mazda
shrieking in flames a dragon bursting
from her brow so this is the fire with
any hatches our dragons and burns miri
in the pyre Danny sees the bloody corpse
of a naked man bouncing and dragging
behind a silver horse the corpse is the
wine seller who tries to poison Danny
under the orders of varus in bulk in
season one when he's caught as
punishment he's dragged behind Danny's
horse until he dies Danny sees a white
lion running through grass taller than a
man this one's kind of obscure in book
one Khal Drogo hunts for Africa a great
white lion that lives in the Dothraki
sea Drogo succeeds brings back a dead
lion and makes a big cloak out of it
Donita wear the cloak makes Danny feel
closer to Drogo after his death
so this line running in the vision is
presumably that same Lion there is a
different interpretation though some
people argue that Jamie is a Lannister
lion and he wears the white cloak of a
Kingsguard so maybe he also symbolically
fits with this vision beneath the mother
of mountains a line of naked Crone's
creep from a great lake and Neil
shivering before Daenerys gray heads
bowed these crowns are the - Colleen of
Vaes Dothrak
the Dothraki city in the show Dany has
already visited here twice but in the
books she hasn't made her second visit
yet they'll surely be differences
between the show and book versions but
this vision looks pretty similar to the
show with the Dothraki kneeling before
Daenerys in a final vision Danny sees
10,000 slaves lifting blood-stained
hands as she races by on her silver
riding like the wind with the slaves
crying mother this is the scene from
book in season 3 where Danny is crowded
by the freed slaves of young Kai in the
vision they reach for her touch her
target her cloak the hem of her skirt
wanting her fire her life and then Dany
snaps out of it and sees all the corpse
he grows undying warlocks warming her
grabbing her apparently trying to kill
her and take her power and her dragons
so Danny's dragon drogon kills them all
and burns down the house of the undying
which may by the way be the fire for
death but yet these are the visions in
the books but let's also have a look at
the visions in the show in the show Dany
has three quick visions in the house of
the undying first Danny sees the throne
room in King's Landing which appears to
have been burned the roofs gone and snow
is falling onto the iron throne in the
books it may be Circe's wildfire
explosion that burns the red cape though
in the show the Wildfire only burns the
Sept so at least in the show we might
have some second burning caused perhaps
by Danny's dragons also we have this
moment of Dany reaching out to touch the
throne but then leaving before she grabs
it may be hinting that Dany will never
quite reach the throne Dany then sees
the wall and it does seem likely that
Dany will go there sometime because
someone needs
destroy the White Walkers army of the
Dead and Danny's dragons do seem the
perfect weapon to defeat them
finally Danny enters a tent and sees her
love Drogo and the son they never had
Rago it's a touching moment where Danny
pauses to reconnect with her past but
she soon moves on and faces the future
her visions end and she kills pyaar pre
with fire much like in the books so what
have we learned from all this we've seen
that visions and dreams in Thrones can
accurately predict the future like this
vision of the red wedding and this one
of the slaves of young Kai who have also
seen that visions and prophecies can be
wrong the prophecy of the stallion who
mounts the world failed and Rhaegar was
wrong about the prince that was promised
and this thing with the stone dragons
also seems not to have happened even
when they are true visions and
prophecies can be so vague and
interpreted in so many ways that they're
usually just not helpful for the
characters of the story in fact they're
often harmful would Miri have kill Drago
if it weren't for the prophecy of the
stallion who mounts the world would
Rhaegar have run off with Liana if it
weren't for the prince that was promised
chasing after prophecies has led to all
sorts of chaos and death as one
character puts it prophecy will bite
your prick off every time but still
there are some tantalizing hints here it
looks like love and fire and treason are
in Danny's future which could very well
connect towards aura high and maybe Jon
Snow as the Slayer of Lies Danny may be
an enemy of Varys and he supposed a GaN
Targaryen and it seems likely that
shield at some point go to the wall to
fight against the White Walkers if
nothing else it's pretty cool to get
these visions of the past with Rhaegar
and le errant Aerys so thanks for
watching this video topic was chosen by
patrons on patreon we hold a big vote
for a video topic every now and then if
you'd like to support all chief Dex
producing high-quality Thrones content
in the long dark off season check out
patreon.com/crashcourse starkville and
Mail seriously Vincent Vaughn fan sent
Muhammad al carbee Canon Drive and Eric
P Davis Cheers